have a product management interview
lined up practice your answer to this
question how would you design an oven
for a person in a wheelchair with this
type of product design question the
interview is trying to test whether you
understand how product design works the
biggest mistake you could make is
jumping straight to thinking about the
product features instead of that start
by asking the interviewer a few
questions to learn more about the user's
needs and wants do they have any other
disabilities that you need to be mindful
of can they sit or stand how exactly
will they be using the product once you
better understand the user their goals
and challenges you can suggest some
solutions or product features also
suggests some moonshot or big creative
ideas it is also important to
demonstrate how you would prioritize
these features what trade-offs you would
consider and what will you ultimately
decide to build as part of your minimum
viable product and why